Ronald I've done it I found your
assistant and he's dope his name is Jean
Ralphy Oh jean-ralphio big t mr. Swanson
two things one it is an absolute honor
to meet you two who is that hot intern
chick out there because honestly yeah
take a seat right here we go
so jean-ralphio you got him right here
leave a message after the bit why do I
want you as my assistant starters access
to the ilis clubs and that's just for
starters I will work for you I'll be on
you 24/7 I'll be like your family I'm
here when you get here in the morning
sure enough I'll be there tucking into
bed at night don't worry it's not gay do
we have questions I think our only
question is when can you start right now
let's do it
thank you for coming in we will talk
cool I feel good about this I know you
can hit me up on Facebook anytime day or
night you know that right
thank you everybody boom so what do you
think of your new assistant I want to
punch you in the face so bad right now
what okay message received I'll keep
looking
thank you bring me the opposite of him
jean-ralphio big t what it do nephew
jean-ralphio
I have a hot investment opportunity that
you were gonna want to jump all over hit
me with a daddy the snakehole loan
order it he's looking for investors no
way yesterday if you would ask me I
would have said no but thank God my
grandfather just died so I am awesome I
have 4,000 bucks all I need you to do is
kick in 6 G's and then you and I are
part owners of the hottest nightclub in
Pawnee also sorry about your grandpa no
worries he was a dick here's the thing I
can kick in 5 G's I should be enough
right no it's not enough I just said I
need 6 G's what about your trust fund my
parents had it amended I don't get
anything to them 50 which is a waste cuz
I'm gonna be a billionaire and Costa
Rica by then eating dolphins and hanging
out with lady singers it's not a huge
deal just sit tight
I'll take care of it you want to come
home with me don't you work at Lady
locker uh-uh k2 the ends of the ope
she's the dopest little short again all
Pawnee Indiana why don't you stop a
party you two remind me of me and my
husband George I got a nails speech so I
brought it an expert jean-ralphio got
throw something on you see if it feels
good sure okay this is what I would do I
would start with a joke joke Vince
Vaughn quote obviously swingers or
Crashers Fred Claus talk about Andy's
ex-girlfriends quote from Love Actually
hold back your tears pause drop the
microphone get out of that [ __ ]
jean-ralphio take me there for you Abed
he's here to help us with the paperwork
man is that your real name
yes oh you could do better than that I'm
to help you out right now your name is
Angelo Angelo thank you so much for
coming out get a thicker tie it looks
weird on you makes your head look like a
fish secondly I don't know where the
paperwork is but when you find it can
you take care of it for us we don't have
any pens cuz we're afraid it's gonna
leak in our shirts lastly I hate the
name Angelo almost switch it up for you
right now your new nickname is jello
shots
you think about that Jay shut down
Ralphie Oh looking hot big t Oh what
damn girl who you trying to impress just
kidding I know walk away yeah you good
try snake juice if you like it you got
to talk it up all night if you don't
I'll shave John Ralphie's head yeah I'd
like to see that hit me lot riding on
this
[Music]
damn if that isn't delicious are to the
old to the end then desist once Gus
wagging besides a Big Ben clock dude you
got to end it on the ride know what I
have had it I got it now we have a
special presentation courtesy of the
folks at entertainment720 I hope you
brought a change of clothes because your
eyes are about to piss tears you nasty
alcohol that you invented government
employees can't use their power to
enhance their personal wealth I totally
get your point Chris it won't happen
again I just don't see any way around it
you're gonna have to sell your shares in
the snake look know
t-pain this guy bothering you this is my
boss okay yeah you want me to write a
rap about your name yes go B to the O to
the SS do what he say and you'll be
successful what up big t stop this must
be the lovely Donna Ashante listen
beautiful let's cut the bull right you
want this I definitely want this th
wants this well let's seal this devil's
three-way right here right now step one
we buy into this club step two we roll
over to the club either in your
mercedes-benz or my pre-owned Acura
Legend step 3 I'd a ger you on the dance
floor just bounce bounce bounce bounce
up yeah while the ladies say it bounce
bounce bounce bounce bounce you say sexy
I'm out why I hate that guy mmm
sorry to hear the news tone we're gonna
miss you around the club
hey you own shirts to wedding Kris make
you so because Kris doesn't know you
know what snitches get stitches
come on don't I'm a natural moneymaker I
got any government for the connections
this was supposed to be the thing that
led to the other thing it's like when
VIN did boiler room that's what led to
him being xxx adored furious yeah no
listen I don't like all this negativity
man why don't you turn that frown upside
digiti huh this sucks man this party
sucks let's go
it's my birthday parties it is looking
forward to tomorrow yes about that I was
wondering is there any chance we could
reschedule I just want to make sure
everything's up to my world-class
standees I like to keep my appointments
son and I like others to do the same of
course yes no problem 8:00 a.m. tomorrow
I think you're gonna be very impressed
with our presentation our presentation
who else is joining you
jean-ralphio with me I didn't realize
you were a part of this of course he is
he's my business partner Shh
clean business partner now and forever
hold up forever 21 21 gun salute salute
your shorts
kaboosh I just reassociate it all over
the moose - that is one of many skills
he brings in this business partnership
what a little shrimp ah
okay rethink that move son there you go
sorry that took forever yeah baby you
missed me oh look at this jean-ralphio
oh hey Andy Andy that's alright name
that's not right name
thank you yeah are you guys are you guys
hanging out together yeah maybe you know
he asked me out so many times I guess he
wore me down I'm very persistent come on
Bernie yeah I can hear you I can come up
one time I waited outside a woman's
house for five days just to show her how
serious I was about wanting to drill her
turns out it was the wrong house
she loved the story anyway we got to
third base over the pants
so cute yeah super cute Wow right do you
want a Remy Martin probably good okay
I'll get you one here we go
are you okay some do you get any sleep
not really
I stayed up most of the night but that's
not important let me tell you about
rent-a-swag
no need Tom I'm in I like doing business
with serious people and when you removed
yourself from the company of that [ __ ]
you showed me you're a serious person
you have your startup money Wow
I appreciate it Tommy tea
you just missed the craziest of crazies
clubs girls dancing naked mom argument
police fleeing the seat hiding in a
dumpster coming here crashing on your
couch for a week cuz technically I'm
homeless
hey mustache I'm gonna hit the couch you
know Abby this is Monalisa Saperstein my
new sales associate
wanna Lisa Saperstein does that mean oh
yeah she's my sister my twin sister from
the same mister thank you so much for
hiring Monalisa it means so much to me
even though honestly she's the worse
she's the worst person in the world huge
skank terrible but thank you it means a
lot of course gotta keep it in the
family
yeah but does it have to be this family
actually that reminds me
the boss man I need to leave early today
because my shrink got me and him tickets
to a pitbull concert and I already
committed to that and so if you say that
I can't go it's like you're taking
something away from me stories really
busy I can I need you to stay I totally
hear you um I also don't like what
you're saying so if you say no I will
start a fire in the bathroom okay I
guess you can go yeah I know again why
did I tell you huh
she's the worst in the world
you